i've been sent a bunch of questions from
a lovely group of very young students so
i'm going to answer them all in one hit
here in this video so the first question
says how did you find your passion for
maths
i think to answer that question there's
sort of two pieces of the puzzle the
first one is that i have an older
brother and he always was very gifted at
maths and loved maths from a much
younger age than me and so when i was
growing up when i was in primary school
even though maths was not a subject
which i was particularly gifted at i
watched my brother do things
particularly he would program
mathematical things into a computer and
i would watch him with interest and say
like what's going on there i was always
very curious even though i didn't
understand it at the time so i'd say
that my brother kind of planted a seed
there of mathematical curiosity and then
when i became a teacher i started to
realize that actually helping people
learn things and making this idea
click and make sense in someone's mind
that's something that i absolutely fell
in love with so i think that's part of
why i enjoy math so much because that
happens all the time when i'm teaching
it how hard is it to teach kids and
what's it like to be a teacher
it can be very challenging to teach kids
in a sense because everything that we're
trying to do when we're teaching is
meant to be something that is you know
you're trying to put your mind into a
sort of
mental acrobatics to wrap its head and
wrap your head around a concept or an
idea or a skill that you've never done
before and so by the nature of it
because you're doing that and the brain
is you know in some ways uncomfortable
when it's trying to do something new
like that that is challenging but at the
same time we're kind of built to learn
you know from the first moment that we
are born we're looking at the world
we're taking insights and sounds and as
we learn to speak and write and interact
with human beings and people around us
these are all things which our brains
are kind of built to do so in that sense
learning is kind of an easy thing it's a
natural thing and so even though it can
be hard i really enjoy doing it
as to what it's like to be a teacher i
think it's full of like i said the joy
of trying to work out what's a great way
to explain something or what's just a
new perspective on an old idea uh it can
be challenging trying to juggle all of
the different kinds of tasks you know
from 9 a.m or whenever your school
starts to 3 pm or whenever your school
ends there's all the parts of being a
teacher that you as a student might see
but there's all kinds of other bits as
well every lesson that i prepare takes
me sometimes hours outside of that
lesson time to think through and to plan
and then there is you know setting tasks
activities exams and then the marking of
those and then things like writing
reports and other sorts of organization
that happen behind the scenes as a
teacher they can keep us pretty busy but
they're all important to help students
learn so that's why it's worth doing
them what path did you take to get where
you are now this is a very simple
question that i feel like has a very
complicated answer it was a very winding
path in a way but i went to university
to train to become a teacher that was
the university of sydney and in some
ways the most automatic thing to do
after that was then to start working in
a school and that's what i did for let's
see six years i taught mathematics and
computing studies as a regular classroom
teacher but then i learned that
after i've been teaching for a little
while and i got a sense of how to do the
job and i i sort of became comfortable
with how to do it and i wasn't just very
confused and learning new things all the
time i started to realize okay i would
like to be i think i have the
opportunity to serve other people by
leading other teachers and supporting
them so that's when i became a head
teacher of mathematics when i joined my
current school cherrywood technology
high school and that was also around the
same time that i started filming my
classroom lessons i didn't have a fancy
camera like the one that i'm looking at
right now i just used my phone and even
though that was a simple act and there
were no grand plans behind it i was just
trying to help a student who was sick
and couldn't get to school and be in our
lessons
even though that was a very simple thing
it kind of opened up an enormous world
that i didn't expect because people
could get to view my teaching from
anywhere in the world just as long as
they had an internet connection and a
device it sort of
helped many people encounter me and get
to know the way that i love to teach and
learn
way more than i would just have in the
regular classroom so that was almost 10
years ago now that i started doing that
and i think that that's what opened the
door to um you know hosting tv shows and
writing books and now working across uh
the new south wales department of
education and supporting teachers all
over the state and even beyond that
sometimes around the country and i've
even had the privilege of going overseas
and working with teachers in other
countries so it's a bit of a winding
path i don't know that i can say like oh
i if i'd planned it this is the way that
it would have worked out a lot of things
happened that um i could never have
expected i didn't know that one and a
half million people would start
subscribing to my youtube channel that
was definitely not part of the plan but
i was delighted that it happened so i
guess the lesson there
is to be
ready for opportunities
to be thinking of ways that you can help
people um and also you know being open
to new thoughts and and trying new
things innovating even if it's a bit
risky um and trying to see what happens
when we do those things to help others
do you prefer teaching primary school
kids more than high school kids in
mathematics i feel like this question
has a little bit of bias in it i love
teaching all
people of all ages and that's not just
me sitting on the fence i don't just
like teaching primary school in high
school i love teaching beyond that in
people who've left school maybe they're
at university i love talking to adults
you know like i said before people who
are also teachers like me or parents or
people you know even beyond that i
really truly love teaching everyone and
there's a different challenge along with
all the different age groups all the
different kinds of people that you teach
i will say i find it harder to teach
primary school kids rather than high
school kids because i was trained how to
teach the high school mathematics
curriculum and the the primary
mathematics curriculum and the syllabus
and all the concepts and ideas there
they're things that i've picked up along
the way you might say well eddie you
actually went to primary school you did
all that maths isn't it easy and i would
say no it's not
any more than being a patient in a
hospital equips you to be a doctor or
eating a meal equips you to be a chef
there's all kinds of knowledge and
skills sort of hiding in the background
or hidden underneath that isn't obvious
when you're learning it it's only sort
of becomes apparent when you're teaching
it so something as simple as say
division i remember the first time that
i was trying to teach
dividing to a group of very young
students and in high school if you say
something like 24 divided by three you
expect the answer just to be eight full
stop that's it end of story but in fact
24 divided by three can mean
how big are the groups if you
divide up 24 into three even groups so
you would have eight things in each
group and that's why the answer is eight
but in the same way you could actually
think of 24 divided by three as
how many groups would you get if you
divided 24 into groups of three so you'd
have a three here three here three here
how many threes would you have and the
answer is eight so those two things are
called partition and quotation and i
didn't know that they existed back when
i was learning to be a teacher at
university and even as a high school
teacher so i find that more challenging
but i do enjoy it because i like
learning things and so teaching primary
school kids gives me the opportunity to
learn even more stuff
who is the teacher who inspired you to
get to the place you are now
i cannot pick out a single teacher who
was the inspiration who helped me to get
to where i am now and achieve the things
that i've achieved and that's because i
had so many wonderful teachers who over
the years sort of contributed each of
the little bits to my story that make me
the person who i am now so for example i
could talk about mrs yates who was my
drama teacher i did drama from year nine
all the way through to year 12 and mrs
yates had me for the hsc which my final
years of school
she taught me the value of taking on a
persona and being able to sort of convey
another person's perspective that isn't
just your own or i could talk about
mr mcfadyen who taught me english for
four years and explained to me the power
of stories and storytelling is something
that i do in every single lesson that i
teach even though the subject that i
teach is mathematics i could talk about
mr brown my agriculture teacher who
taught me the importance of treating
students as not just people who are
supposed to learn in your class but as
fellow human beings with incredible
dignity and value or i could talk about
mr best my music teacher
who taught me the lesson of patience i
think music teachers are amazing because
they are so gifted at music and they can
often play multiple instruments but they
have to have incredible patience because
they're dealing with people who do not
know what to do with their instruments
at all and they sound terrible
especially to begin with and then they
will develop into skill so every single
one of those teachers that i just named
and many more besides they each were
inspirations to me and i'm just very
grateful to have had many of them who've
mentored me and continue to teach me
what it means to be a great teacher
how do you make maths look easy for kids
who find it hard
this is an interesting question because
i don't find maths easy i find it a
subject which even though i teach it
i've always found it something uh
intellectually you know it's it's full
of hard thinking and sort of getting
things wrong and then trying again and
learning lessons so i'm glad some people
think that i make it look easy um i
guess what i would say is firstly what i
just mentioned the fact that i can
empathize with people when they find
that's hard to learn because i found
maths hard to learn and i still do in
many ways i think that empathy is very
important because there's nothing um
more discouraging than when someone says
to you oh it's very obvious why don't
you understand i think i understand and
everyone else understands why don't you
i've never been like that in my classes
because i don't find things easy to
understand i have to work really hard at
them so that's one thing secondly i
would say
connecting it to knowledge that we
already possess i think is very
important if you started reading a book
and you started reading instead of at
the beginning if you started reading in
the middle of course you would find it
confusing because you don't know who any
of the characters are there's like all
these kinds of events that have happened
leading up to the thing you're reading
about but you don't know what any of
those events
were or what they mean and so you'll
kind of be thinking what does it signify
what's the importance of this event
happening i don't know because i don't
have any of the background knowledge so
often we learn mathematics and we kind
of start in the middle not intentionally
but maybe there were things from earlier
on maybe we were sick or maybe we
changed from one school to another there
can be any number of reasons why we're
missing as it were earlier chapters in
the story of mathematics that we're
learning so it's hardly a surprise then
as we progress further we might think oh
i'm a bit confused i've got gaps in my
understanding and i'm trying to build to
change metaphors on a sort of wobbly
foundation and that can lead to
confusion so i guess um to try and help
mathematics learning be easier rather
than harder it's important to be able to
identify like part of my job is to not
just tell students and convey ideas but
to actually
learn from students and listen and say
what is it that you already know what
are the things you don't know that
actually are important to the things
we're learning today if i can identify
what those are
and address any weaknesses or gaps that
you have that will help you get a firmer
grip on the new ideas concepts and
skills that we're learning
so thank you for those questions i hope
you found those answers helpful all the
best in your mathematical learning
journey i hope i get to meet you one day